hey guys hey guys I'm angry Joe I mean
and I'm Larry I'm a market player ah
wait is Fred
I'm Greg Alva I'm John this is John we
just came back from Power Rangers the
movie though he's gonna have a ridge
after we watch this we're going to
review that the video will be up the
videos up now
with it yep videos up yeah I mean after
this you can go and watch our Power
Rangers movie review cross-promotion oh
yeah
hell yeah hey check that out this one's
got look how that worked out that way
vertical integration or advertising for
our own company strange junkies honest
trailers Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
the movie you know how this works I do
I like a few simply I love the service
[Music]
you love the Power Rangers when you were
educated would be so weird yeah after he
doesn't watch me just watch the movie is
gonna be really strict are you gonna
like [ __ ] with our review at all I
wonder
[Music]
you love the Power Rangers when you were
a kid
now take a trip down memory lane and
realize what was I thinking
[Music]
terrible homicide by men Power Rangers
the movie before they try to make a
grounded reboot out of rainbows to the
teenagers karate fighter grumble be ah
is it the first Ranger project that
didn't rely on archived Japanese footage
which only makes it worse
now what's their excuse you know it's
that when the rapping pumpkin looks
better than your CGI robot whoa you're
ready to fight me back with me I'm with
a rock back bad follow the exact same
formula that cranked out over 800
episodes until I read some of the
monsters sub Power Rangers fight their
minions hand a hand someone gets really
big I feel like I got and the Rangers
Morgan to his own Saturday but this time
everyone parents get ready to committing
mass suicide and I'm burning the housing
whoa daga dorg return to the night aha
every group in the high school to the
fire department has their own
competitive skydiving team and get
caught because all your favourite
teenagers with attitude have returned up
- the attitude explode in any engine
also none of the actors were actually
teenagers and three of them are actually
replacing your favorites from the show
but still three of your favorite non
teenagers without attitude and did
contract disputes are here why Tommy
the only one you care about Kimberly the
decals are and Billy the nerd was
bullied so badly he walked off the show
I was worried that I might pick my own
dude again dark when Sydney all straight
angel Grove muhahahaha
Freddy Krueger ish slime monster welcome
the Rangers travel to Sydney off another
planet to gain the power of the Magette
II which I believe is italian for ninja
and all new way to make it easier to
swap the actors out with their stunt
doubles now they'll come together to
save the universe from evil with a fresh
set of action figures nice or cool job
do etc I love that a very awful looking
Zord complete with emergency jump
kicking at you
oh right in the bulk and skull Vulcan
scholar good Renaldo that was basically
a live-action cartoon war was so
forgettable the show ignored it and did
their own episode about major powers
instead you now put them on now John
deep within your soul but at least it
gave more fuel to heavy Power Rangers
fans most important question are Tommy
and Kimberley hooking up or what now the
kitchens out of the picture they have to
be right it's so big
sorry and then they actually kick your
head and the brain the sorceress from
the he-man movie haha Fred Savage
Bela from Raiders of the Lost Ark
seriously needed a paycheck
pointless back handspring
[Laughter]
yeah let's go get the other one and the
morning girl and teenage Mormon ninja
diggers
okay smells like teenager
so club the next bike spray oh yeah that
ain't swingin junkies one more 90s
nostalgia then take a trip back down
memory lane
what ableism a car not are on a straight
nose news great it would northern the
dungeon heretofore if it's still get
carried away we lose about for the wrong
hand of the normal now
hi Yonny early it's morphin time
how many lows could rob lowe raw if that
logan problem sport i do the return this
year is harry cooter and a chamber of
same reports and i'm on over microscopic
silica volcano coney OSes was another
fighter one yeah of the reading comment
one yeah this is the first time i've
seen footage from the Power Rangers
movie since like that day we watched in
fourth grade really ever how cool it was
younger that was like an event threat oh
man help I saw that Peters or not but I
remember like oh I saw that bad baby was
a theaters I was jacked when so I
finally brought it in like the day
before summer vacation this is a video
from screen jockeys we went to a show
called tournament of nerds that was at
the UCB theater on Saturday night how
Rudnick was one of the hosts he's
hilarious but the other person know is
some strange oumax- was one of the
judges and it really cool it was
actually awesome like it's like a you
know an uncensored unfiltered more
something that you could kind of see on
screen junkies
yeah but you know it's like too much I
don't know if the magic is the negative
the MPM lies the be here in room yeah
and it's personal you know it's
personable if it's not just like trying
to get this online and get a bunch of
you it's great
before you have to all kinda there Joe
star who I know I was there for the
longest time as the funniest person on
screen joking that I've thought that for
the longest time and he played the
character cook Tommy he get from the
batter Rangers yeah but it wasn't me to
the show was that they had characters
from you know films and TV shows that
you loved and you need to bring about
them at a time and they would
you can get a minute to argue why their
character yeah and the other one sucks
basically a you talk [ __ ] on the other
character while talking yourself up it's
an elimination challenge like you got
you can fight rounds to the end but he
did this cool thing where he took a
hybrid of Tommy from Power Rangers and
who do you got his like today yeah from
being you know Jesus doesn't tap Jesus
and then they are fighting like the
clothesline or something is ceric cerous
ha sighs I don't think you defended him
you know doing his fries I hope you some
how does a character raw like balance
tree-huggers it was if it's one of the
funniest things of every a gallon that
was the size of living night of comedy
yeah that's a little citation that's
good skydiving scene that had no song is
in the skydiving scene know which one
Red Hot Chili Peppers higher ground
thank you yeah people people feel like a
fairy tale creature like fell down a
well that was so cool and Tommy got the
snowboard yeah I guess I guess is yeah
yeah the coolest one in the crew
speaking in the drive-thru Bordelaise
there these movies were like ridiculous
and fun yeah they're gonna land yeah
like as a kid I remember this is
everything you wanted it to be I will
say if we're going by like what what a
movie is I feel like this Power Rangers
movie that we saw is probably better
than this one although this one honors
the show Tootie well this one is the
[ __ ] yeah but is the show it's like
directly the show and and you know it'll
have an extra magic because uh yeah but
as opposed to the I don't know it's
weird cuz you know the new ones there
are things that are similar about them
that make them both enjoyable even
though yeah for like the modern-day
version of power ii yeah i think because
the movies kind of cheesy but in the
right
way you know yeah match Power Ranger
because I feel like they the people who
were making empowering this time thought
this stuff was just so cool sometimes
yeah like they must have been aware that
this is a little silly yeah at the same
time that I think they thought they were
doing some cool ashes this is cool in
some way cuz it just it commits 100% to
it so it's like cheesy but you gotta
love it you know yeah well everything
feels sincere and that's kind of how the
new one feels but if they did like a
modern-day version of that where at
times or tries to be more serious you
know just having it recontextualized
here is Freddy Krueger like when I was a
kid I didn't pick that up especially
with the side-by-sides they show is this
like it seems like that's exactly
intentional I feel like they just wanted
to put Freddie in you know it sure has
those Vulcan skull it has bulk and has
gone why are they in the movie they
would have fit in this movie to someone
they might a fitness movie and plus like
how cool would it have been to hear the
modern-day throwback version of their
like silly music yeah they always had
that like silly theme song on the show
that would play when they would come in
I felt like it would switch to being an
old like slapstick so I boosters yeah
and I can see that transcribe a little
bit fun oh no I feel like we could have
in Bolton school could have been bulk
and skull you know like two bullies that
no one is actually afraid of yeah yeah
that's kind of exist in there a little
microcosm and they get into hijinks and
they don't succeed yeah I think they
should do like a TV series of bulk and
skull in the Power Rangers universes you
franchisors know a better call Saul and
just go like living together it should
be like I'll be over and drama bad like
this shows building something special I
could feel and like bulk has some kind
of dubious operation he's working on
it's got a really really ten so I was
just trying to paint the bills in like
you know he's a junkie to now to like
they're really like afraid of each other
it's basically mr. white Jessica is like
you know I want to explore that you know
I'm getting any greedy like you know
this movies dark and the suicide thing
from the happening yeah they did I had
the suicide family comes a happening
yeah so many children were gonna lose
their parents that's too bad
yeah - Pat - Pat is going to make sure
they're not doing the drugs the power in
you to tell you not to do I think the
whole thing was an allegory you know
it's a metaphor for how parenting sucks
balls you know like you become so numb
to this world every day every day about
that it was a month I just feel barren
ting every day you got your whole life
revolves around this kid then after a
while you go nominee you want to kill
yourself and not even shaking stops you
could pay attention and make sure you're
alive still and there's your eating you
maintaining your body that's the thing
about powering you don't realize how
deep this show actually one is all about
like mad about you know then and you
know martial arts and you know being
like what's that come food was like the
show kung fu but for small children and
Kimberly was he was but I had this chick
in here who like trains them on my
mountain place I don't remember the
details of the Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers movie but she's like half naked
she was also the chicken starship
troopers who Kawada the chicks Kasparov
and he was into but then she gets hit
from behind scumbag killed her you see
Starship Troopers no I never did reading
it spoilers soon but I haven't seen
Casper Van Dien in public again no
didn't I was excited I like that listen
you can subscribe to the real rejects
we're going to do our Power Rangers
review and standpoint yeah I feel like
as what we wanted to do subscribe to the
real rejects subscribe to screen junkies
please this guy this [ __ ] his
name is John Humphrey
oh no I'm going to want to follow this
guy Instagram and Twitter our reason for
Jerry I'm [ __ ] serious about that
[ __ ] he's also the social manager Mia
you know I'm trying to say a plumb house
and the real rejects take care bye-bye I
papi